[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 150 something
555. all right it's not prime that's
easy enough to detect
we are uh I'm I'm not gonna candy coat
this we are staring down the barrel of
2023. yeah we are happy New Year
everyone and for those of you watching
you'll see that while we're in the same
place we're in a different uh a
different setup here we were done we
were done being super comfortable on our
lovely sofa but it was uh it was
creating a certain amount of slouchiness
so here we are back at our table and
chairs that we were broadcasting from in
Portland and uh it's still our temporary
Studio but uh this will mean fewer
animals on camera we do have a dog below
us yes snoring so you can still enjoy
that whether you're watching or
listening she's not story at the moment
but I'm sure she will
she's not she is
I I definitely either I'm hallucinating
that the dog is snoring or she's snoring
which I'm betting it's the latter
yeah except for the fact that she's not
snoring all right well maybe it's the
former all right
um that's gonna make this interesting it
will yeah it'll hold the whole episode
so today we're going to talk to you
about
um
Whole Food Shoppers and their ethos and
Organic certification and igg4
and uh how mRNA vaccination against
covid seems to affect it
and the other IGG classes they're called
classes is that right yeah one one Iggs
one through four uh what we think we
know now in light of a recent paper that
has been published and there's also a
Lancet paper we're going to talk about a
little bit today finding a surprising
rate of monkey pox and women except not
actually so we go down that rabbit hole
a bit and talk about the Lancet and uh
just how not awesome it and other
medical journals and scientific journals
in general seem to be at the moment with
a few notable exceptions I will say
although we don't have anything to talk
about this week bmj British medical
journal has been one of the beacons of
light and Sanity throughout uh
throughout covid and it what it seems to
indicate is that actually an
editor-in-chief and I don't actually
even know I don't even know his name I
don't
but like it takes apparently
one guy
and like I'm sure there needs to be
agreement to some degree but uh one guy
to be courageous and to stand up to the
um stand up to stupid and stand up to to
bad science and bmj the British medical
journal is doing it Lancet is not
yeah yeah I mean uh we will we will get
back to this topic but there's also a
question the Faustian bargain that those
who try to do this the right way while
remaining in the good graces of the
system at large end up
doing good and doing their own kind of
damage by creating the impression of a
middle ground that is actually a social
Middle Ground not a scientific Middle
Ground yeah the institutions are fine
mostly you know it's it's fine just uh
just get along so that you can get your
word out and it's not really working is
it for the most part right
um anyway we will return to the journal
question in segment three here yes
indeed
uh so uh we follow these live streams
the live q a our final q a of the year
will be shortly after we finish this
live stream you're listening to right
now you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
we encourage you to uh if you're
watching on YouTube consider switching
over to Odyssey where the chat is live
and of course this will be going up on
Spotify and all of the audio podcast uh
services that uh as usual after after
we're done here
uh this week on in Natural Selections
which is where I write weekly on my sub
stack natural selections.substack.com I
did a highlights from 2022 which began
by recalling a couple of the guest posts
that I had from the truckers Freedom
Convoy early in 2022 which was really
extraordinary we had
um
both one of one of the Dan's whom I
published and Tara's piece on her
daughter Mila
um I'm reminded of as well as a lot of
other stuff there so um encourage you to
encourage you to go there we of course
have our store
darkhorsestore.org with lots of lots of
good stuff although I sort of expect and
maybe hope that many people are kind of
done with buying stuff for the moment if
if they did some amount of buying over
the holidays but we will recall to you
that we are supported by you and we
appreciate you subscribing and liking
and sharing both full episodes and also
Clips on our Dark Horse podcast Clips
channels on both YouTube and odyssey
and uh you can also support us by
joining us at our patreons where you get
access to private monthly q and A's we
had ours two weeks ago this this month
so that so as not to be doing our
private q a on Christmas and they're
just a lot of fun and usually the first
Saturdays and Sundays of the month you
have smaller conversations as well
you're not going to be doing one
tomorrow because it's New Year's Day so
next weekend
you will be having these conversations
on both Saturday and Sunday mornings
true and new episode uh new guest
episode of Dark Horse out as of
yesterday I believe uh seem Dr Asim
Malhotra right which has nothing to do
with patreon but um that is that is on
on Dark Horse and apologies that it came
so late but it's a it's a great
conversation so also on patreon you can
join our Discord server where for
instance there are um book clubs that
you can join and discuss with people of
all sorts of all sorts of demographics
and finally of course we have sponsors
uh three at the top of most hours that
we do live streams and we select them
carefully we really stand by them and
they stand by us and we are appreciative
for that so without further Ado our
three sponsors for this episode
our first sponsor this week is thesis
thesis makes no Tropics no Tropics are
nutrients found in nature or in the
human body that enhance mental
performance in areas such as motivation
creativity mood memory focus and
cognitive processing they work best when
combined with taking care of yourself
generally which includes eating real
food moving your body often in a variety
of ways and getting good sleep
you're probably already using nootropic
as one of the most commonly consumed
ones is caffeine
effective nootropics allow people to
optimize their focus energy and mood
based on the demands of the day for some
people no Tropics can replace the
Pharmaceuticals that are often used to
tackle problems like for instance ADHD
thesis is unusual in nootropic market
and taking a very personalized approach
they do not assume that what works for
you will work for your dad or vice versa
or that what worked for you when you
were under deadline for a stressful
project will work for you when you're
trying to inspire yourself for a passion
project you've been dreaming of for
years for instance
when thesis first started out they
blinded their customers to what blend
they were taking and took careful data
on how everyone responded to the various
plans just as some people become alert
after a cup of coffee and others can
fall right asleep so too do all no
Tropics have different effects on
different people now more than 2500
customers and millions of data points
later thesis has created a
recommendation algorithm to predict
which blends of no Tropics will work
best for any given customer
the process is simple go to their
website take a short quiz and they'll
send a starter kit with four different
blend recommendations to try over the
course of a month we've tried several
Blends now haven't liked them all but
have found several intriguing which is
exactly what you would expect to get on
their approach my two favorites are
called creativity and Logic the
creativity blend Smooths things out a
bit adds Clarity the logic blend
facilitates Focus but your results will
vary with fully personalizable Blends
there is likely to be a thesis that is
right for you to get your own customized
thesis starter kit go online to take
thesis.com Darkhorse take the quiz and
use code Dark Horse at checkout for 10
off your first box
our second sponsor this week is eight
sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod helps you get good sleep
as we discussed in the Sleep chapter of
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century intelligent life that found its
way to Earth might be surprised by a lot
of what it found here but not by the
fact of sleep or of dreams sleep is
necessary without good sleep we are
destined to be unhealthy and
unproductive consistently good sleep can
help reduce the likelihood of serious
health issues decrease the risk of heart
disease lower blood pressure and even
reduce the risk of Alzheimer's but more
than 30 percent of Americans struggle
with sleep and temperature is one of the
main reasons couples who sleep together
Brett often have very different optimal
sleep temperatures
which can cause all sorts of
disagreements my temperature feels under
attack at this moment it is yeah Aid
sleep allows fine-tuned temperature
regulation for both people having a cool
room and a warm bed if you're reasonable
is a luxury that basically makes easy to
obtain
all right that's one perspective sure
yes uh the pro the Pod Pro cover by
eight sleep is the only sleep technology
that dynamically cools and heats each
side of the bed to maintain the optimal
sleeping temperature for what your body
needs with the Pod you can start
sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit as some of us like or as hot
as 110 degrees Fahrenheit which seems
too warm for everyone
foreign
the temperature of the cover will adjust
each side of the bed based on your sleep
stages Biometrics and bedroom
temperature reacting dynamically to
create the optimal sleeping environment
eight sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by 40
percent and get 30 percent more deep
sleep on average with more restful sleep
overall you may see improvements in
physical recovery hormone regulation and
mental Clarity even if you want to sleep
really really really cold
finally the alive future which can make
you no which can wake you with
temperature change under slight chest
level vibrations is much gentler than
any standard alarm and it's really great
actually everything about this product
is great we're both a little skeptical
when H sleep approached us we said we'll
try it but really not convinced but we
are sold and we are surprised at how
much we appreciate this uh this the Pod
cover the bed
so go to eatsleep.com Darkhorse that's
e-i-g-h-t-sleep.com uh Slash Dark Horse
to check out the Pod Pro cover and save
150 at checkout eight sleep currently
ships within the US Canada the UK select
countries in the EU and Australia
all right well I'm uh I'm now over that
attack on my preferred temperature okay
and um I'm experiencing some
dyslexiophobia here looking at this uh
the script which I have not read before
phobia yes it's the anxiety I made up
the term but it is the anxiety that
comes when you know you're going to have
to read something in public and fear
that there may be a term in there that
you will stumble over that a normal
person could read easily but we'll find
out if that happens we will we will all
right our finals how about this I
promise to make fun of you for your
preferred sleeping temperature but not
for your dyslexia
that seems fair I think so all right our
final sponsor of the year is soul a
sustainable Orthopedic footwear company
Seoul is one of our two Footwear
sponsors and we love them both they are
quite different from one another yet
they both have an evolutionary approach
to creating shoes that help uh feet get
and stay healthy
uh and people become more mobile because
of them Soul intentionally brings back
structure with both their shoes and
their signature footbeds Soul aims with
its Footwear to return feet to health
and shoes by Soul are beautiful in fact
um travel being what it is I had to
limit my Footwear when I went to uh
Florida recently and it had to have at
least one pair of shoes that would go
with my suit and that pair of shoes was
a nice leather pair of soles slightly
high top that I wore for everything
except biking they're beautiful yeah
they are they are lovely and they worked
great exploring in Florida
sole footbeds are the industry standards
do they resist crocodiles or sorry
alligators they repel crocodiles and
alligators I don't know if they resist I
managed to steer clear okay uh clear
enough in any case
um Soul footbeds are the industry I'm
not true guys they're great shoes but I
don't I wouldn't buy them if you've got
an alligator problem and who doesn't
oh dude okay sorry did not helpful all
right yeah no now my dyslexia anxiety is
all the more elevated all right sole
footbeds are the industry standard in
over-the-counter supported insoles and
inserts they are moldable for custom
comfort giving you all the benefits of
personal personalized support at a
fraction of the price of orthotics sole
footbeds are made from recycled Cork and
include a signature supportive Arch
which is clinically proven to reduce
Arch strain in your feet this is
especially effective in helping recovery
from plantar fasciitis which I can
pronounce because I've had it
uh but no one wearing your souls no this
was many years ago and it is a truly
excruciating condition which affects
more than two million Americans along
with a range of other ailments from shin
splints which are also agonizing to hip
knee and back pain sole footbeds also
promote neutral alignment and good
posture and are particularly effective
at preventing fatigue when standing or
walking for long hours on hard surfaces
or near crocodilians it says so right
there they believe in the quality of
their product so much that they're sure
that once you feel the Comfort pain
relief performance enhancement and
injury prevention benefits of sole
footbeds you will want them in every
shoe you own they've also got an end of
the year sale going on right now with up
to 75 percent off on selected shoes
sandals and footbeds all of which we
highly recommend Dark Horse listeners
should visit yoursoul.com Darkhorse to
get 50 off any footbed they believe in
the quality of their products so much
that they're sure that you will feel the
Comfort pain relief and performance
enhancement and injury prevention
benefits of sole footbeds and you will
want them in every shoe you own once
again get 50 off by entering the code
Darkhorse 50 at checkout at y o u r s o
l e.com
well done
ish dog is snoring the dog
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
the nature of time
suggests that just because she is
snoring Now does not mean that she's
always been snoring
um
let's put it this way most of the time
that she is snoring she has been snoring
before we check in with her so for some
indefinite period before now when we
both agree if he is snoring she was
snoring perhaps without her agreement
don't play
2023 is going to be long isn't it yes
yes
long and trying but at least we have our
wonderful sons and our dog and our cats
wherever they are uh to help us keep
things
awesome I hope okay let's launch into it
uh I was thinking I was on the mainland
recently uh since we don't live on the
mainland anymore and I find myself in a
Whole Foods
um
Whole Foods has never been my favorite
store to be in uh but uh it's it
pretends anyway to have an ethos that is
very much the sort of
the sort of grocery shopping experience
that we do prefer so you know when
possible we shop at farmers markets and
at Food co-ops and actually Portland was
an exception on the Food Co-op front
there were a few co-ops but they weren't
that close to us and they weren't as
awesome as the co-ops in other places
where we've lived
and so Whole Foods is usually not my
first choice but I was on the mainland I
needed to pick up some meat for holiday
meals and knew that I was likely to be
able to find some high quality meat
hopefully that was grass grass-fed grass
finished
um and excuse me
and it led me to think about I was sort
of looking at all these other mostly you
know holiday food Shoppers in Whole
Foods uh which I want to say something
about the end of this little segment but
I actually ended up sort of going down a
little rabbit hole because I thought
well you know Whole Foods is actually
two uh shopping at farmers markets of
food co-ops a little bit like USD
Organic certification is to actually
growing your food responsibly and
carefully and in in the way that would
have been traditional
100 years ago through 10 000 years ago
Maybe not maybe not exactly that but but
close enough
and I just thought okay well I remember
uh when we had relationships with
farmers at for instance the Olympia
Farmers Market I would very often uh
hear from them that you know what we're
not certified organic but we have
everything in place and either sometimes
they would say we're working towards
that and it's you know it's a process
because you have to let the you know the
soil remediate and such if if there had
been uh conventional farming practices
on the land
um but more often they would say we are
doing everything actually to a higher
standard than the US Department of
Agriculture requires in order to get
Organic certification but we're not
going through the bureaucratic rigmarole
which is itself a giant set of hassles
and hurdles and expenses and uh
basically that means that you know you
the buyer with a relationship with me
the small farmer will have to trust me
as opposed to the government but I can
bring you the better you know better
food at Better Price without going
through the bureaucratic intervention so
that was sort of what I had in my head
about USDA certification go for it so I
just wanted to point out we may have
been through the logic on this before
but this is game theoretically
absolutely top category right one should
you know just we I think we maybe in a
recent episode talked about how one
should evaluate two shampoos one of
which had no advertising Associated and
the other had uh you know an expensive
model or whatever and the answer is
psychologically the consumer should
penalize the advertised one even if they
look approximately equal because the
point is whatever wasn't spent on the
model might have been spent on better
ingredients or uh you know r d or
whatever it is that would make a better
shampoo and in this case
attacks the de facto tax that exists on
organic quote unquote organic foods that
comes from all of that bureaucracy is
then taken away from the prophet and the
quality of the farmer doing the farming
so in some sense if you can trust your
farmer and your farmer's market often
allows you to do that because you meet
them face to face and that's probably a
better guarantee than a government
certification at this point and in fact
we had a CSA for many years a community
supported agriculture subscription which
is you know if you have one in your area
it's fantastic to do because it provides
basically insurance against the vagaries
of weather and climate for the farmers
such that if they have a bad year you
get less in your box but you've paid up
front but if they have a boon year then
you get more in your box but you know
the CSA that we had with a we biked to
pick up our box every week and we had a
relationship with them and we actually
brought some kids that we were watching
including our own a couple of years to
do a farm tour and so like you can
actually see if you were not in a
position either because you don't want
to or because you just can't grow your
own food it's the next best thing yeah
and so in some sense if you are in such
a position
uncertified organic is even Superior to
officially organic assuming that the
trust linkage works exactly I will point
out I remember from that tour the um
carrot washing apparatus which I was
totally fascinated by which is basically
like a big cement mixer in which the
carrots are dumped in and the water
flows through and the carrots are sort
of agitated and the carrots roll and all
of the dirt sort of flies off them which
yeah
neither here nor there but I thought it
was really awesome no it was oh um
absolutely so
um as to the question that you raised at
the end here of whether or not
uncertified organic might actually be
superior to certified organic I was
thinking the same things like well okay
so you don't have to you don't have to
buy into the bureaucratic bloat in the
system and therefore you stand to
actually get a better product and
support your local farmers more but I
didn't know
uh this thing that is now true about
Organic certification and I didn't I
didn't have time to go all the way down
this road but if you want to show my
screen here Zach I've got a couple of
these are just PDFs from websites which
I'll link to in the show notes from USDA
us Tournament of Agriculture and they've
got an eight-part series of posts on how
it is to go how you should go about
getting your USDA organic certification
if that's something that you're
interested in so organic 101 five steps
to Organic certification this was posted
uh in December of 2020
uh so this is uh you know solid nine
months or so into covid uh the vaccines
have just been uh released or not
available to almost anyone yet except
for some medical professionals and down
here we have under step three receive
inspection uh for live stoppings the
inspection uh may include
inspection of feed production and
purchase records feed rations animal
living conditions preventative health
management practices EG vaccinations
health records and the number and
conditions of animals present on the
farm holy moly now I thought
vaccination is possibly required for
Organic certification that doesn't seem
to be what I knew to be true of organic
certifications so
um
and I know nothing about what these
vaccinations are so I went to another
um of their posts uh this is uh an
earlier one in their series but they've
reposted it as of July 28 2022. this is
organic 101 allowed and prohibited
substances
okay and so first they say organic
standards are designed to allow natural
substances in organic farming while
prohibiting synthetic substances that's
it in a nutshell What organic standards
are supposed to do allow natural
substances we can argue all day long
about what natural means and whether or
not natural is inherently good obviously
it's not and they say things like
actually you can't use arsenic and
organic farming practices
allow natural substances while
prohibiting synthetic substances
some synthetic substances are listed as
exceptions to the basic rule and are
allowed for use in organic agriculture
for instance pheromones have long been
used as an effective non-toxic way to
confuse insects that may otherwise
infest organic crops especially fruit
likewise vaccines for animals are
important disease prevention tools
against many infectious diseases
especially since antibiotic therapy is
prohibited in organic livestock
now I could not actually figure out
because then it gets very confusing and
muddled and you uh
I I maybe by Design Maybe not maybe I'll
just leave that leave that as an open
question whether or not
these several points in the USDA site
that I find the suggestion that your
inspection for organic livestock
certification may actually include you
requiring to show the receipts that your
animals are vaccinated is that actually
true if it is true which it seems to be
but I don't know this for sure then the
original framing of What organic means
according to the USDA itself which is
allowing natural substances while
prohibiting synthetic substances
has been expanded to now be requiring
some synthetic substances
requiring substances that are created
in a lab as something that is that is
mandated for Organic certification
now provides even more reason that
uncertified organic where you actually
depart a little bit potentially from uh
what is required by USDA certification
standards is superior because the fact
is that in general and this is not going
to be true if you're if you've got
feedlots if you if you're cramming the
animals together although those are
normally not practices that are approved
for Organic certification anyway
that animals that are healthy that are
able to go outside that are that are
going to do the things that we want to
be able to do as humans as well because
mostly the animals that we eat are also
social
be outside eat the food that they were
evolved to eat all of this are not good
require the high-tech interventions that
we are we are wanting to shove on them
all right several questions one so I
have not encountered this before yeah I
took what you read initially potentially
to be about the vaccination of workers
tell me that's not that I misunderstood
what was said I believe that is a
misunderstanding because the sentence
Begins for livestock okay
um all right so now let's follow that as
a livestock requirement yes
a
this puts a whole different spin on the
shenanigans that surrounded the
redefinition of vaccines in order to uh
to make that term relevant to the novel
vaccination platforms especially the
MRNA platform that has been at the
central of our covert effort yeah
the so here's here's the line of logic
I'm seeing unfold here with
I must say a good degree of Horror
you redefine the term vaccine so that
this new platform which is a radical
departure from what we historically mean
by that term doesn't create immunity it
creates uh it turns you into a vaccine
Factory do you remember what the
redefinition was from into by any chance
uh it's subtle but I do I do believe I
remember okay I believe that the idea
was a vaccine induces immunity right and
that it had to be altered because these
that was the original yeah these
inoculations do not create immunity what
they do is they induce a process in you
that creates immunity in other words
it's not the introduction of something
that hasn't turned you into a vaccine
Factory it turn you into a vaccine
Factory so that's one issue the other
issue
um not a vaccine Factory but yeah
effectively effectively in the factory
um and in a very in a very haphazard way
the other question surrounded whether or
not they prevent the transmission of the
disease
right so in any case the reason that
this is so horrifying in the context of
something like Organic certification
is what we learned painfully slowly in
unpacking what these things actually did
over the course yeah was we learned that
certain things that we were sort of
gently nudged into assuming that turned
out to be totally false had implications
for health so I'm thinking in particular
of the substitution of the
pseudo-uridines for the uracils in the
MRNA transcripts right so what we were
initially led to imagine was look we're
going to inject you with this stuff it's
going to short term cause some cells to
produce some proteins that will alert
your immune system and then it will be
gone because that's what happens to
mrnas
yeah that's what happens to mrnas when
you don't include this pseudo-uridine in
every spot where there was a uracil so
what they did is they which makes those
mrnas thus altered resistant to the uh
RNA Aces yeah the MRNA Aces that would
otherwise be destroying any
free-floating mRNA in the intercellular
space right for lots of reasons some of
which I think will come up later in our
in our discussion of igg4 but
the point is okay so now you've got a
thing which is a vaccine by virtue of
the fact that they change the damn
definition and the idea is well vaccine
is really it's it's synthetic but it's
leveraging an organic process that you
know you know okay yeah super elegant
until you start telling me that you're
introducing mrnas that the body doesn't
have a mechanism for taking apart
because you substituted a pseudo uridine
for every damn uracil and that means
this thing has to find its way out of
the body some new way or get degraded
very slowly by entropy over time meaning
that you have fragments of this thing
this is an insane plan and the other
change the definition of vaccine having
vaccines be in the literature on Organic
certification means that anything could
be introduced under this word umbrella
without us being an either wiser right
worse we are now beginning to see so at
the beginning of the vaccination
campaign you will of course remember
that there was all of this talk about
shedding which responsible voices like
you and me largely dismissed not because
it was impossible that anybody would
ever shed a
um either a spike protein produced by
this or an mRNA that they had been
injected with but because the dosage
would be so low compared to P you know
if a person survives vaccination which
almost everybody does then the tiny
dosage that you would get by shedding
would be trivial almost no matter what
it was right I mean there's a trivial
amount of Cyanide and apple seeds and if
you swallow an apple seed you don't die
because it's small but
that said there is now a uh responsible
and growing chorus of people who say not
so fast actually the shedding thing
turns out to be real I'm still unsure
how it could be important given the
dosage issue but there are ways in which
the dosage can be high for example
lactation for example having sex with
somebody who has uh been vaccinated and
yeah although those those two things
wouldn't normally be lumped under the
category heading of shedding well I mean
you know sexual transmission and they
are infant transmission are different
they are or they aren't but the basic
point is look there was no big fat
warning to pregnant women don't you know
nurse your babies after you've done this
even if internally that was understood
by the the Pharma companies who made it
but here's the point okay so now
you're going to go to the market and
you're going to buy organic beef let's
say okay and you're going to assume
that organic means something like what
it's always meant which is basically
produced with natural processes right
would you be terribly upset if the cow
that the beef had come from had been
inoculated in some tried and true
fashion against uh you know some sort of
pathogen that cows reflected with not
really because it would be more or less
a trivial issue however as soon as you
tell me that that cow might have been
injected with a you know a
pseudo-uridine
infused mRNA coated lipid nanoparticles
and now I'm thinking look
a
so I'm not saying that that's happening
yet but I'm saying it's coming part of
what's been driving this is that this
platform is lucrative because you can
basically make a vaccine by swapping a
sequence into something you've already
built for other purposes right
um but it's also true that what we have
here is a is a static set of definitions
and and apparently words well the
meaning of the words is sort of
cryptically changing behind the scenes
where you know as as the USDA cite
specifically notes as I read from uh
USDA certified organic meat uh cannot
have been given
antibiotics there may be some rare
exceptions but basically antibiotics are
off the table if you want you cannot be
using antibiotics especially with the
sort of regularity that you know sort of
prophylactically across the board like a
lot of major meat producers do which is
terrific
however it is terrific that they are
excluded yes terrific that they're
excluded however
if I were given a choice between
um you know you're gonna buy a half a
cow uh or the whole cow you can buy a
large chunk of a cow that has been
produced
um well and it was grass it was grazing
up until the very end
um
but uh it got sick at some point and
there was an antibiotic treatment for
the sickness that it got that that uh
that it was given and it was a short
course and that was a couple years
before it went to slaughter or the thing
that it got sick with well we've come up
with this brand new thing that we're
going to call a vaccine and it's maybe
got the pseudo-yuridine in it and it's
got all these other and it's got the
lipid nanoparticles and stuff and we're
vaccinating that cow every single year
or whatever the crazy schedule is
decided by the manufacturer
well the cow number one which had a
single course of antibiotics for a
sickness that came on and that was
treated and then it cleared the system
is can't be certified organic and cow
too maybe can and again we're making up
these vaccines for cows we don't know
that these vaccines right
um but I would fastly prefer to eat cow
number one the meat from cow number one
uh which had a course or maybe even a
couple of courses right like antibiotics
um as you know as we have said over and
over and over again are one of the great
incredible human successes of Western
medicine as we have believed vaccines to
be as well but that doesn't mean that
the you know widespread use in every
possible uh moment is the right way to
use them and so the USDA organic
certification uh position which is
absolutely no antibiotics but because
that then yes vaccines
seems to really misunderstand complex
systems Evolution you know what you know
what it is that humans who are seeking
Organic certification uh both for
themselves if they're Farmers or for
their for their food if they're you know
consumers uh would want like it just it
just is so unnuanced as to really miss
the book well I'm going to depart with
you a little bit I don't feel like this
is unnuanced I feel like we are having
our well no antibiotics ever is
unnuanced right but that's that's that
is a and it's easy to it's easy to
certify you know if someone is coming in
you know oh god I've got you know my job
is usdi organic sort of certifier and
I've got to do 40 Farms this week I have
no idea what the workload is but I'm
sure it's too high right well it's much
easier to have a list of like wait you
you know you give a course of
antibiotics that cow is not cannot be
organic certified like that's all I have
to know right it's so in that Way It Is
Well the rule may be on Nuance yes what
I'm saying is that the formulations here
are smuggling in absolutely radical
stuff as if it's minor and that that is
the gaming of our assumptions and so you
and I have an instinct about an
antibiotic I do not want uh meat from an
animal that was given antibiotics to
increase its rate of growth right
I don't want
meat from an animal that was given
antibiotics in the last two months of
its life
I'm not troubled by an animal that was
given an antibiotic a year earlier why
because I know something about what that
animal is made of I know it has a liver
I know it has kidneys I know it will
have gone through a process of
degradation I know that the antibiotics
themselves are the products of biology
and so the basic point is that cow's
ancestors were encountering these toxins
in the wild the the whole system is
built to be anti-fragile by selection
and once you start introducing this
radically new stuff and the point is
what is it
oh it's an MRA mRNA covered in some some
lipid
okay you've just not quite yeah you just
screwed me over twice right because it's
not really an mRNA and that isn't lipid
in the sense of some fat but never shows
up that way in nature right and so you
know okay you've gamed my assumptions
and you've gotten me to be more relaxed
than I should have been but now okay
so somebody's done something to some cow
right they've injected it with lipid
nanoparticles covering some mRNA for
some purpose again this is fiction this
is fiction but let's say they've done
that and now I go to the store and I see
hey there's two kinds of beef I'm
willing to pay the extra price I want
this organic one right and when I my
assumption is the organic one is it
going to be perfectly free from all
toxins no the animal will have breathed
it will have been out in the world
they're you know tractors on the farm
they have exhaust whatever it's not
perfectly free of everything as none of
us are but it'll be 95 of the way there
not if you injected it with this crazy
crap and now my behavior with respect to
it should actually probably be the
inverse of my instinct right if I want
to eat a rare piece of beef right and
I've gotten something that is certified
organic my sense is what's in that beef
mostly beef right what if what's in that
black cow stuff right I want it and you
know if it's not you know long ago we
had a discussion about why I thought the
pandemic might bring ground beef to an
end and I at some point we want to go
back to this that obviously didn't
happen
um and it's worth going back through why
I got it wrong or maybe just early but
and you're interested in the evolution
of arboreal cows is that it
oh goodness nice one yes
um not so much honorary dad joke oh
thank you
um but does that make me trans I hope
not
um
it doesn't really matter you identify as
you want just don't change anything but
um but the point is if you're gonna if
you gave me a steak and you said you
know if I was starving and you said
here's a steak
that animal was vaccinated with mRNA
coated in lipid nanoparticles something
that we now call a vaccine my answer is
yep I'd like it well done
right why because you're gonna at least
potentially break apart some of the
stuff that's dangerous to me with heat
is it gonna make a steak I really want
to eat no but if I'm starving I'd much
rather eat it after you've cooked the
hell out of that thing right so it just
inverts the assumptions right right and
that's exactly the opposite inclination
for you know at least at least many cuts
of meat you know some some cuts of meat
you know want to be cooked long and slow
and you know and all this but most of us
who you know can afford to and are
interested in forking out uh more money
for really high grade uh beef steaks I
don't want them all done you know medium
rare is the is the usual thing at the
moment and some people go towards medium
but like between medium medium rare is
where generally uh you know if you're
looking at a rib buyer in New York or
something that's that's what you're
looking at and you're saying yeah in
this case if you don't know what's in it
you know maybe at least
are out the window as soon as you do
this where whereas you know let's
suppose that you know your your meat
farmer as we did when we lived in
Olympia
um
well okay I don't necessarily know what
they did and didn't inject the animal
with if they say well it's you know it's
it's uncertified organic right I'm doing
what I should do but I do know that if
my Farmer is also eating what he or she
produces right and they are on alert
about all of the synthetic stuff that
we've been told is safe that turns out
not to be they probably won't have
injected the animal with this stuff for
their own well-being so it might be
again a higher level of protection there
that's right
okay well then just wrap this up before
we segue to talking about igg4
um the thing I was before I went down
the what has happened to USDA or gang
certification Rabbit Hole was walking
around Whole Foods
with my you know fam I got a brisket I
got a prime rib I got some you know I
got some good pieces of meat in my cart
but I'm looking at the clientele
uh who you know looked kind of like me
right and they got similar things in
their carts and I'm thinking
these are people who are choosing to
spend more money in part because they
can and so there is a you know there's
there's nothing but privilege in a Whole
Foods right
um but they have they have come to the
conclusion
that eating food that has not been
uh pesticided insecticided uh antibiotic
uh you know across you know for its
entire life given growth hormone if it's
Dairy that you're eating you know all
these things these are people who have
come to this decision that they are they
because they can they are willing to
spend more for such food especially for
their family right a lot a lot of people
will say well even if I'm sort of on the
cusp of being able to afford it
definitely for my children because I
know that they're growing right
this is also the demographic though that
and I don't have I don't have a chart
here but I believe that it is sort of
common knowledge uh that you know
well-heeled people shopping at Whole
Foods are some of the people who were
most adamant about getting the novel
vaccines and honestly also about giving
them to their children
so
where's the disconnect like you know
this this is a this is a question that
we've come back to over and over and
over again but I was struck by it in
what felt like a new way to me looking
around going how are you making these
choices that cost you more money than
they than they need to
in order to get food that I understand
to be better for me and that are better
for you if they are what they claim they
are you know putting aside what I've
since learned about USDA organic
certification Etc
how is it that you are also the people
who are yelling for mandates that
everyone get this very new very
synthetic
very hyper novel treatment that actually
isn't even safer effective like how do
those two things live in the same head
well unfortunately I think I know how
they do and it's something that you and
I have actually talked about recently
which is and I'm not I don't want to
portray people as being this way I think
some people are this way across every
topic and all of us are this way across
certain topics but most people do not
have a model in their minds about how
stuff works right most people
if they took biology they took it in
high school
sort of you know they they got through
the test they didn't think too deeply
about it maybe they were struck by a
concept here or there but they didn't
walk away with a a model of how a
creature actually functions they walked
away with some some factual knowledge
and by the way a lot of that is on the
teachers who failed to convey the the
intuitive fascinating model that might
have been passed along I thought biology
was incredibly boring after I took it in
high school I had that bad a biology
teacher yeah I got an A and I was like
well if I can get an A in a class it's
that boring what possibly could be of
interest there yeah I I had a very
different experience you had a different
teacher I did I think I would have ended
up I mean I was biologically as my
grandfather used to point out
um Eric landing and math was a little
bit of a surprise but me Landing in
biology wasn't because I was always
fascinated by Critters but I also did
benefit from a couple of biology
teachers who really were good at making
it intuitive and
um and that fostered my my love of it
but anyway the point is most people
don't have a model right yeah what they
had have in lieu of a model I would call
a Cartesian nightmare right so the
Descartes became troubled by the fact
that he didn't know almost anything on
his own right he took almost everything
on the word of somebody who claimed to
have discovered it yeah and that is an
alarming thing to realize now in fact
there's nothing wrong with it it's the
only way especially as the range of
things that one might know has grown
radically in the last couple hundred
years
um you can't know if you set yourself
the job of establishing everything that
you believe personally you'll get
nowhere right you just don't have time
to run that many experiments and so we
all have to take a lot of stuff on a
kind of Faith but the question is how
good is your model of how Faith works
right if what you do is you proxy your
belief to a group of people who you know
they all went to college they studied
different things oh there's a doctor in
the group there's a physicist there's a
an engineer and a lawyer and whatever
and the point is well okay this group
has expertise in almost all the things
you'd want to know and so more or less
you know to the extent that they become
persuaded that something is dangerous I
should probably watch out to the extent
that they become persuaded that
something is safe they're probably about
right and the point is that probably
works until somebody starts gaming it in
the way that has now taken off well and
it's more easily gamed if no one in the
group and this will often be the case in
hyper-educated groups of people if no
one in the group
has skills in the physical world
because education is often correlated
with disdain her physical work right I
mean I mean this is Criminal frankly we
have let that happen but
um that very often people who are
educated say oh well you know I've
outsourced having to take care of any of
my physical needs maybe you know the
exception of cooking but you know I
certainly don't do I you know oh we did
our bathroom no you had you paid someone
to do your bathroom for you right like
this on this language like
it's one of my pet peeves like I hate it
when people who can afford to have other
people do their work for them
linguistically make the claim that they
have done it because they had the money
to to be able to afford to pay other
people but if you have a group of people
who actually don't
manifest physical things in the world in
any way by Craft by you know physical
activity some something yeah then they
are much more likely to miss
um glaring logical errors when they show
up yeah totally totally agree and it has
made them sitting ducks uh for this
very sophisticated effort to slide stuff
by us right and you know they got us
when they said mRNA I thought yeah
that's bound to be short term still
doesn't make it safe but
it's not a long term issue it's a
short-term one right and then you know
the the degree to which all of our
assumptions even those of us who are
carrying a good model in the exact
location are being gamed is spectacular
but what it means is
I mean we've seen
a wholesale shift in what the people on
a given team believe over time right a
number of authoritarian things the
number of anti-egalitarian things that
the blue team is now spouting as if
they're self-evident is amazing right
well and I mean just
before the 2020 election
there were prominent Democrats including
our current vice president who were
saying that they wouldn't take the
vaccine developed under Trump uh until
and unless I don't even know what the
conditions were right but you know the
valence switched and you know no one on
Blue Team on team blue wants to talk
about actually these vaccines were
developed entirely under the president
that you hate so much right and it took
apparently no more persuading except
that now there's someone different in
the Oval Office who had nothing to do
with it and of course Trump had nothing
to do with it either like neither
presidents don't have anything to do
with the vaccine development although
they can you know encourage it but you
know as if who is in the Oval Office
changes how safe or effective a medical
a novel medical treatment is but but
you're making the error right there what
is it that's a model and you're saying
that model doesn't make any sense yeah
right the idea so what's a model that
the person in the white house has a big
influence on the technology that I might
put around so I'm saying that model
doesn't make any sense well but the
point is you're described driving is it
as if folks have a model running in
their minds that doesn't work my point
is it's not even a model they don't have
a model they don't have a model what
they have is a Jersey right the people
wearing blue tend to spout the
scientifically wise things and so if
what I more or less do it's like driving
the flow of traffic you may not know
what the last speed limit sign said but
you look around and the traffic you know
there's the guy whizzing by in the left
lane and there's a couple slow pokes in
the right lane but you're somewhere in
the ballpark of reasonable and the point
is
if you do that you end up flow of
traffic on a normal Road and if you
somehow Bumble into the Indy 500 then
the flow of traffic doesn't tell you
anything about what you can do you know
what though actually this is a
fascinating analogy because
um many modern cars
now have a pop-up that tells you what
the speed limit is yeah and there are
many examples like that that happens to
be the one that you use and that you
know I know because we have one or two
we definitely have a vehicle that
doesn't do that because it's from the
90s but at least one of our vehicles
does and I think that in part this is
this is this is this allows the creeping
authoritarianism that's my point because
because we are most of us are now being
informed constantly of like what you're
supposed to do you don't need to even
look around and be like I'm gonna go
with the flow you don't even need to do
that it's like oh I know what I'm
supposed to do I don't even need to pay
attention to like why is that guy going
like that
well
what I'm arguing is we are forced to
proxy our understanding on a great many
things socially right we have to defer
to people who know more than we do in
places that we don't know much now
hopefully what you and I do is we have a
model that hopefully does not get ahead
of what we actually understand that will
allow us to detect some kind of illogic
right even if somebody's talking about
physics and we're not physicists the
point is they've got to stay within the
realm of reasonable or explain why
they're departing before you know we're
going to be able to listen to the stuff
that we can't comment on because it's
beyond our knowledge
but if you toss out models entirely and
your point is look these people they
ain't perfect I'm sure they're wrong
about some stuff we'll laugh about 20
years from now
but
they're cutting it I mean you know
they've gone to the right schools
they've talked to the right isn't there
a model implicitlyn no there's a model
of they're educated my point is there's
the failure of the idea of models at the
point that you go from having to proxy
the majority of what you believe to
other people to well I guess if I'm
doing that for the majority of stuff why
don't I just do it for everything I'll
hang out with the smart people and I'll
be smart and my point is the smart
people are shopping at Whole Foods
they're buying organic because it is
safer right and that means they have no
mechanism for detecting that something
has oh those people have money
they buy organic because it's safer now
what definition do we have to swap
before we can sell them our stuff under
their label right and they will feel
sophisticated serving it at their
cocktail parties and they won't have any
idea why their friends are getting
Parkinson's disease right so it's it's
exactly that once you socially proxy the
point is you are a Sitting Duck for
anything that can pump stuff into your
social environment through a social
Channel which is what happened right we
watched virtually every doctor screw up
covid right how is that possible these
people studied medicine after they get
it so wrong we knew until covet like
everyone knew uh that the medical
profession was enthralled to Big Pharma
like this this that was a a widespread
commonly understood sort of you know
democratically held position right that
the you know the junkets and the free
stuff and the farmer reps showing up in
the office and giving you lots of stuff
and telling you the words to use to help
diagnose and push drought particular
drugs on particular patients who showed
up with things that maybe you couldn't
diagnose but probably it's this oh and
of course if it's if you give them that
they're gonna need to give them this for
the side effects for that and like this
was all no no yes but until and like but
but now like you you say anything about
that it's like oh oh you're one of those
people you're one of those people we
were all talking about this five years
ago 10 years ago 15 years ago we were we
were all talking about this right but
the problem you know I don't know how to
convey it but the problem is we were all
talking about it using a Common Language
but there are two species using that
language there's more than that but
they're broadly speaking you got people
who are running some sort of a model
sometimes it's crude sometimes it's
misinformed but at least it's a model
right the model tells you when something
that is complete nonsense has been
pumped in because suddenly your model
throws an error and it's like well
that can't be right I mean people watch
this happen on our channel in real time
right what was the error that we
couldn't get past they kept telling us
this stuff was safe and there's no way
on Earth they could possibly have known
it yeah right so it was that it was like
okay some social thing is broadcasting
from every speaker in the house from
every periodical this is safe and I can
you know on the back of an envelope tell
you why that can't be true well I guess
we see this too on the other side we've
seen it personally where uh and you know
I don't I care less and less about the
labels of left and right and Democrat
and Republican and I just I just liberal
conservative like I just they just mean
almost nothing anymore right
but for a while it seemed very important
because it was true to be repeatedly
saying nope still liberal still
Progressive like you know actually
politics haven't changed in the wake of
Evergreen for instance uh but uh but our
understanding of who is doing what on
behalf of whom is changing
and a lot of people on the right people
who you know were also still using those
labels at the time many of whom have
also stopped would say no no you're
conservatives now and the response that
both of you both you and I gave
independently in in many venues was nope
not a conservative because your
definition is about who you're hanging
out with yeah and this is this is a
political position not a social position
and this actually really failed to
compute for a lot of people on on both
sides but we happened to run into it
failing to compute for people who were
lifelong conservatives like no if you're
talking to me and we're getting all
along then you must be conservative it's
like just because we're friends doesn't
mean that we are the same thing in every
regard like the the social reality
doesn't create the other reality and I
do think that this actually is a
misunderstanding across across domain
yep no you found you found the exact
proof right because to say you're a
conservative because you believe in
these things as I a conservative believe
in them is this social proxy and the
point is look no there's actually an
epistemology I can show you how I know
I'm not a conservative despite the fact
that I agree with you that a bunch of
those things that you're defending need
to be conserved it's not that there's no
conservatism but the point is hey guess
what we can't stay here we can't
continue to do what we're doing we need
progress to save us that's why I'm a
progressive right it's that simple so
that's a model yeah it's not you know we
could go into much greater depth but the
point is that's a very simple model and
it allows one to parse the speech who is
a conservative who is a liberal who is a
moderate right we can parse that speech
using that model and in any case I guess
my my overarching point would be
it may be that social proxying is the
slam dunk winner in a certain place
where you have nothing at stake in
certain eras when the thing isn't lying
to you uh right and left right it may be
highly efficient but as soon as the
thing starts lying to you as a matter of
regular course you need a model it's the
only hope of figuring out what to listen
to yeah
okay uh if you show my screen here for a
moment this is our segue to uh to what
you were hoping to talk about this is a
tweet from Health and Human Services
hhs.gov the official government Twitter
account wow
your government Twitter account yeah yep
um it reads if your last booster was
before September so this is from
December 16th if your last booster was
before September you should protect
yourself and those you love with an
updated covet vaccine
catch covet again and you might not keep
it to yourself
that's an advertisement for these
vaccines
um amazing right
amazing it's so many different so many
different levels they also turned off
replies
of course they did they've learned that
they have to do this to keep the people
who are running a model from overrunning
their replies and pointing out how
stupid they're being yes
um because people can be so mean people
can be mean but I mean that you know
that just proves how much Insanity you
can jam into a tweet if you're really
dedicated oh man yeah
block transmission and the whole idea
the word should in that tweet if you
were passed however many months you
should get a booster yeah that's right
it's three I didn't see any age
stratification in that claim no you it's
all used any you if you're a you you
should get a booster right that's just
insane yeah right that there's there's
no defense for this there's no there's
obviously no model running behind that
other than how can we fool them no you
should protect yourself and those you
love because if you don't maybe you
don't love them as much as you think you
do yeah it's about love love and it
comes in a syringe
oh my God yeah sorry about that okay
well that seems like a perfect lovely
place to um to move over into talking
about this uh this result the science
paper igg4 yeah okay so many people will
have heard IGG 4 suddenly emerge into
public Consciousness and I thought the
best thing for us to do was actually try
to provide kind of a basic I don't want
to say a course but a mini crash course
and how to understand what's even being
discussed so that you can build the
model that will allow you to understand
what its implication is for for example
your own decision to get uh one of these
boosters or not do okay so you're gonna
start at the beginning or do you want to
show the paper might as well show the
paper I've got I've got it up if you
oh that's not aware all right we are
going to show you the paper so this
showed up in science Immunology on the
22nd I think I don't remember yeah the
22nd 22nd
um so with this paper talks about after
um
oddly
proclaiming the obvious value of the uh
mRNA vaccines what this paper discusses
is a from what I understand highly
unusual shift in the subclass of
antibody that shows up in people who
have been vaccinated with the MRNA
vaccines after their third dose yeah so
there's a my screen should not be on for
this but there's a figure yeah can you
take it off so I can just find figure
one here
um
figure one is pretty
pretty clear although it's I'm just
going to show part C of figure one here
so this is what you're talking about
here the launch student analysis of
vaccine-induced antibody response
um with igg1 IG in pale blue igg2 igg3
igg4 the other the other ones and what
you see is basically after the um
I don't remember what Fu refers to here
there's so many little acronyms in this
paper but um basically you have 89 of
igg-1 response
um after the first or maybe it's the
second uh dose of the MRNA vaccine and
by the time you're at the again I don't
remember if it's the fourth or the
anyway after a booster or two you're
down to 73 igg-1 and whereas ig4 was
almost non-existent almost untraceable
after your first doses uh by your by
your second booster I think it is you've
got almost 20 percent IGG for production
right so what I want to do is first just
translate this into English and then
help you understand why it is that the
heterodox people are freaking out about
this result and I don't think the Freak
Out is unwarranted I think this really
is a dramatic and important result that
we need to understand first thing to
understand so we can take this off so
yeah is that IG as in IGG and igg4 4
means immunoglobulin which is a synonym
for antibody so if you've been hearing
about antibodies this is a class this is
really a sub igg4 is a subclass of
antibody there are major classes of
antibodies which you may have heard
discussed during the pandemic there's
igga which is specific to mucosal
reactions one of the critiques people
will have heard of these vaccines is
that you're vaccinating people in the
arm for a respiratory virus and it turns
out that there is a profound impact of
where in the body your immunity is right
so if you're going to get a you know a
cut and tetanus is going to get into
your blood right you want your immunity
in the blood where the pathogen is going
to show up so that the immune system can
shut it down before you get sick right
if you're going to get if you're going
to inhale the thing right you want your
mucosa to have the antibodies if your
response is antibody based and so anyway
where the where the response happens it
has something to do with with the main
classes of antibodies IGS
and there are subclasses so
IGG is one of the major classes of
antibodies involved in shutting down
pathogens and they do this in various
ways I think we've discussed it here
before
antibodies have that familiar y shape
the tips of the Y's right the tips of
the Y's have a very unique
electromagnetic conformation that sticks
to something specific right so you have
these things basically floating around
waiting for the inverse set of magnets
and when they land on them something
happens and that something can be that
the antibody sticks to the something and
just gums it up so it can't do its job
right like imagine that you uh you know
there were tanks invading your country
and you had a giant Silly String gun
that just glued up the tank right and
the point is all that tank is not a tank
anymore it can't work it's too full of
gum
so anyway their antibodies that just
stick to stuff and cause it not to be
able to do its thing right you can
imagine if you gummed up the spike
protein on coronavirus that that
coronavirus can't use the spike protein
to get into the cells that's that's the
idea right but
this whole system the system of immunity
of which antibodies are really half the
story so
um B cells which we've all heard of make
antibodies they have receptors on their
surface but they also make free floating
antibodies which they secrete and these
antibodies go out and they do things
they gum up stuff they can also stick
stuff together and Signal something
called a macrophage to come and consume
it and destroy it anyway it's it's a
it's a multi
um
it's a multi-faceted response to to
pathogens but the whole thing depends on
an underlying principle called self
non-self-recognition okay so the system
has to be able to figure out what
belongs to you as a result of all the
stuff that you do physiologically and it
has to not interfere with that stuff and
then it has to detect all of the stuff
that isn't you and figure out what to do
about it now in general
the system starts out by recognizing
molecules that you yourself don't make
that look biological
and assuming that they are hostile right
that causes some problems though because
you eat stuff that isn't you right you
inhale stuff that isn't you and the
level of reaction although the eating
stuff that isn't you is going through
the donut hole that is your intestinal
system so it's technically outside of
your body right and so that's that's why
leaky gut syndrome and such is such a
problem and celiac disease where the
stuff that's not supposed to be
uh recognizable by your immune system at
all gets out of your gut and into your
bloodstream and then suddenly your body
can start seeing a bunch of stuff and
freaking out about it right so there's
all kinds of stuff about your epithelium
keeping the stuff that's not supposed to
be exposed to your immune system outside
of you whether outside of you is in your
Elementary Canal or physically outside
all of you
um but anyway so the system is extremely
elegant and the thing is it's far more
elegant than we yet understand we are
still at a very crude level of
understanding how this works but we do
know that in utero the system
basically fires right imagine you as a
mammal inside your mother's uterus
you're not exposed to a lot of stuff
from the outside
the system can say all right which of
our antibody producing cells are being
triggered by stuff that we're seeing
those aren't good they react to self get
rid of them right so now by leaving only
cells that didn't react to you you've
got a non-self-recognition system
beautiful until you get into the world
and things get complex right now here's
the amazing thing now I remember as a I
guess I would have been a
college student I had seasonal allergies
and I went to the allergist and the
allergist did a panel and figured out
what I was allergic to and then cooked
up some inoculations
and I asked because I'm biologically
oriented I'm like um what's in those and
he's like all the stuff you're allergic
to
it's like well
that doesn't sound like a very good idea
why are you inoculating me with the
stuff that I'm allergic to that sounds
I've also clearly already exposed to it
it's what's causing the problem that
sent me in here exactly right so I I
asked I don't understand why why does
this work I'm not saying it doesn't but
why does it work and he went through a
very complicated explanation that meant
nothing in other words they didn't
really know
okay did he think he did he think they
knew I think he kind of thought they
knew in the way that doctors sometimes
think they know but they're out of their
depth and I'm not arguing that that is
in and of itself thinking you know is
bad but doing something that works even
though you don't know why it works
that's not inherently wrong and that you
know that's how medicine functioned
right you you understand stuff a lot
before you understand exactly why it
functions the way it does but anyway I
was alarmed at how little seemed to be
understood by you know somebody directly
in the field
well it turns out he did not take the
inoculations I did and then I stopped
and actually that's right my allergies
went away years later I think because I
changed all sorts of other stuff that
had to do with a general inflammation
problem that was causing me to be
exposed to many more antigens than I
should have been but
to make a long story short
self non-self-recognition is established
in utero but then it is maintained by a
very elaborate system that modulates
immunity
now here's the punch line of that story
igg4 is a subclass of antibodies
involved I'm not saying this is all it's
involved in but it is involved in the
down regulation of immunity right so
imagine that you face some molecule out
in the world and you're overreacting to
it right that's bad right that causes
all kinds of problems and one thing that
the body can do is it can update its
understanding of what is hostile and
what isn't hostile and it can cause you
to not react to something right it's
like look
by analogy
you have a panic response your Panic
response is presumably there because a
certain number of ancestors have
survived something frightening and then
left Offspring as a result of the fact
that they panicked appropriately right
there are all kinds of situations in
which you don't want to panic right most
of them most of them is Right vast
majority especially in modern times but
you know if you're in water
Panic is not good right learning not to
panic in water right like you and I grew
up on a coast right
as you're dragged out to sea by the
riptide
Panic is not your friend right if you
fight that Riptide you will exhaust
yourself and you may well drown if you
realize that Riptides are short entities
and you let it take you out which is
frightening as hell and then you swim
horizontally you will escape that
Riptide and then you can swim in right
not panicking is the key to surviving so
Riptides tend to cause Panic as you
notice it's happening learning not to
panic is the key to survival igt4 is
like this right to the extent that
something you're encountering is
um a bummer because of your reaction to
it not reacting to it is key and so it
is not terribly surprising that the
system has a mechanism for down
regulating
um a immune response
so I don't I don't want to I don't want
to jump ahead here yeah but as I
understand the paper I've never made a
claim to be an immunologist and I don't
know as much Immunology as you do
um they have found that the greater the
exposure to the MRNA vaccines
the higher the ratio of igg4 among a
total of all of the IGG
um cohort that your body is producing is
which given the piece of information you
just added to the discussion means that
your immune system is being tamped down
um potentially the more boosters you get
they also find that
um
those who have been vaccinated and then
get exposed to covid also are producing
more igg4
and they went and looked at a couple of
other vaccines I think it was typhoid
maybe you don't need to show my screen
here yet but um uh no not typhoid
tetanus and RSV it's they say the igg4
subclass does not Prevail after repeated
vaccination with tetanus toxoid or
respiratories
Sensational Virus Infection these
findings support the notion that class
switching to igg4 is not a general
consequence of repeated antigen exposure
in form of vaccinations or infections
yep so this is and it's specific to the
MRNA covered vaccines
um and not and not generalizable at
least to two other vaccines or well one
other vaccine and one of their infection
that are active in the human population
now right yeah now I don't want to
pretend anybody really understands what
this all implies yeah but it does open
some very scary possibilities yes so one
thing is that the repeated vaccination
and you know you and I and others have
warned about what we don't know about
continuing to send the same alert signal
into the immune system in a dynamic
complex system right so these vaccines
were insane in a number of ways one of
them is they're too freaking narrow
right they are you are playing you are
like a child playing against a tennis
pro right you are delivering an
evolutionary challenge that is not
difficult for this virus to overcome and
you were doing so repeatedly right you
keep playing the same move in
Tic-tac-toe and not learning that it
doesn't work right so
okay
the we've talked about things like
um original antigenic sin right original
antigenic sin means that if you overly
train your immune system to have a
particular reaction it doesn't get to
experiment and find a better reaction
right so that's one Hazard here antibody
dependent enhancement right you're
talking about an evolved entity that is
trying to get into your cells to do its
own bidding right
it has not it has encountered antibodies
before it happens all the time and so
the question is is it built in such a
way that it can actually utilize those
antibodies in a jiu jitsu-like way to
get into a cell that it couldn't
otherwise invade right of course that
has been experimented with by selection
and so that is always a danger when
you're inducing an immunity so how do we
know that's not going to happen here
well this adds a whole new category
right yeah to the extent that your body
and my guess is if we study long enough
we will find that there are pathogens
that have figured out this trick maybe
even covid has figured out this trick
from before but
the idea that there is a system for
attenuating immunity and that it is
being elevated at a spectacular level I
mean the from non-existent to 20 of the
IGG response yeah from something like
0.04 it might have been 0.4 but you know
they they variously they gave a number
but then they also said almost not
measurable right it's almost not
measurable which you would expect at the
beginning to the extent that you're
fending off something the attenuation
antibody is not the one that you want to
be producing it's counterproductive
right it's its own goal right so
the fact that this thing is being
elevated tells us a if you know they've
only surveyed a couple of previous
vaccines but they've said hey look here
we've got some vaccines we know actually
work and it's not triggering this B if
you've been vaccinated and then you get
covered it is being triggered that's
interesting that is interesting here
here's this is also interesting from the
discussion of the paper furthermore we
observed significantly higher igg4
levels after two doses of chromadati
which I also never know how to pronounce
the Pfizer vaccine I thought it was
Community but Community okay I'll start
over I'll go with komorandi furthermore
they write in this science Immunology
paper released December 22nd of this
year furthermore we observe
significantly higher igg4 levels after
two doses of community mRNA vaccine
compared to a hetero heterologous
immunization regimen with a primary vac
severia vaccination followed by one dose
of community although the total
anti-spike IGG response was comparable
this argues against the hypothesis that
repeated exposure to the spike protein
itself triggers the unusual igg4
response so uh you know they've they've
this is It's a small study and there's a
lot here that is beyond my ability to
assess directly in terms of their
methods and um and you know the tools
that they're using but they seem to have
covered a lot of basis in terms of like
oh my God does this happen whenever you
get repeatedly exposed to a pathogen
nope not with RSV how about whenever you
get repeatedly exposed to a vaccine well
no not with again what was it um
tetanus I think
um not with tetanus uh okay how about if
you just get vaccinated a lot against
covet but it's different covered
vaccines nope not that either
it's the MRNA covered vaccines
repeatedly being vaccinated against the
beginning repeated exposure to that
they don't say moderna here but my guess
would be that either Pfizer or moderna
would do you know you could you could
mix those two and you would get the same
response but I don't know they don't
think that's implied by the paper
um yeah so it so that that argues that
this isn't a strict case of original
antigenic sin right right because it's
not uh it's not the antigen that's doing
it is something more complex but
and it could be you know it could be a
lot of things right this was such an
alarming strange result
I'm not saying that this is right or
that I even believe it I'm just saying
one hypothesis is that the destruction
to the immune system that comes from the
pseudo-uridine enriched
mrnas being consumed by macrophages do
we know that that destruction happens I
don't think we know that yet but it's
certainly likely that macrophages which
are
um
capable of digesting normal stuff might
choke on pseudo-uridine enriched mrnas
that are Spilled Out when a T Cell
destroys a pseudo-infected uh
transfected mRNA Spike producing cell
right
that could be resulting in a shift in
immunity as a result of the you know
some kind of exhaustion now do I immune
exhaustion
yeah let's put it this way my model
doesn't tell me how you get from
macrophages uh ingesting this stuff to
that kind of exhaustion but who knows we
now have a question on the table which
is why are we seeing this radical shift
in the direction of standing down an
immune response where you would expect
it to be elevated yes right
um so that's troubling what's also
troubling
is because this is
mediated by an antibody it is mediated
based on a particular electromagnetic
signature on the surface of whatever it
is that these IGG fours are targeted at
presumably spy protein
so what that means is that
if you imagine
your immune system can react to just
about anything large biological
molecules that way it can recognize any
Invader whether your ancestors ever saw
it before or not
all right and then if you reacted to
everything you'd react to yourself you'd
tear yourself apart before you were ever
born
so you get rid of all of the stuff that
looks like you right that digs a big
hole in your immune system right all the
stuff you yourself make is placed off
limits from immune attack
autoimmunity is the result of your
immunes of that border not being well
policed and there are various reasons
that that might happen and a pathogen
might learn to look like you enough that
the immune system would either Let it Go
free or pursue it into that hole and
start attacking you also right so
something like
um uh rheumatoid arthritis right where
you're attacking your own tissues might
be the result of uh you know that damned
if you do damned if you don't immune uh
predicament
but
the point is look okay we've specified a
sequence
and now the immune system has reacted in
the way that we've done this by
apparently standing down an immune
response now we're creating an
opportunity for the pathogen right and
not just this pathogen we're creating an
opportunity for any pathogen that can
evolutionarily produce a signal that
triggers that same reaction right so at
exactly well not exactly the moment at
this moment
in the global North
when many illnesses are cropping up
because people are inside and um and
it's dry and respiratory viruses just
have an easier time transmitting for
both of those reasons
uh sure enough we have what is shocking
shocking to all of the health
professionals in public health
authorities is a sharp rise in very bad
cases of both flu and RSV and your point
is
given you know if this paper holds if
the result in this paper published week
and a half ago in science Immunology
holds
and it turns out that the more exposed
you have been to the MRNA vaccines
against covid
the more likely you are to be basically
having your own immune system tamped
down by your immune system itself you
may well be more susceptible to not just
covid but to all the other stuff out
there yes you were at least and
worst of all because we jumped in with
both feet and vaccinated
you know everyone who's willing billions
of people
um I don't know what fraction of that
billions got an mRNA uh vaccine but
let's say it's a billion people a
majority I think well actually I don't
know Russia and China China used a very
different yeah thing so I don't know
what the answer is but let's say it's a
billion people Nothing is dependent on
the exact number
um what we've created is again a
function experiment for the other
viruses that we weren't tampering with
to see whether they can figure out uh
this formula for escaping oopsie
immunity right so look
foreign
you and I used to say all the time I
don't know why we stopped saying it
because it's been the message all along
but we used to say all the time welcome
to complex systems that's right welcome
to complex systems is our shorthand for
you are dealing with a system you don't
know nearly enough about to make any
sort of a radical change and think you
know what's going to happen
right to the extent that you are
deploying a new vaccine you don't know
even if it's a traditional platform
vaccine we've seen this go wrong before
where people have released a vaccine
that was made in a traditional way and
it had unforeseen impacts the idea that
you could get away with speeding up the
development of some radically new
platform of vaccine and assume that it
was going to be without major harms or
impacts was never made any sense and
here what we're seeing I I think
potentially we're seeing a couple of
different contributing factors we've got
the immune system is a complex system
inside a person a complex system inside
a society a complex system inside a
pandemic a complex system right that is
a nightmare from the point of view of
predicting net impact we are now looking
at a population level change that may
have severe implications not just for
this pathogen but for others so that's
one lesson is this is human
biological hubris coming back to us in a
uh
the details are shocking the fact of us
having been this wrong cannot be
shocking that was foreseeable but the
other thing is us being the public
health apparatus yeah Humanity what we
net did was insane
um the other thing is you and I used to
take a lot of crap from various people
over the question of lab leak and
whether or not it quote unquote matters
right there was a whole
yeah mid-wit
kind of conclusion that well it's a lot
of that going around so much yeah the
midwits have definitely had their their
day
um but their perspective was formal
distribution of wittery
yeah right
um
their perspective was look
wherever it came from
it's here
let's deal with it and the answer what
we have said from the beginning is no no
no no no what you did to this virus has
implications for everything it has
implications for what we should expect
it to do for what we should expect it to
be capable of it has implications it
will respond to various treatments how
it will respond to various treatments
how dangerous it is and how good your
model is of predicting that so here's
another place right we've been dismissed
as revolve into lower virulence over
time as all the other viruses tend to do
not all of them but most of them well
maybe right this is the first of its
kind this is the this is the first of
its kind and
um also how much you can infer about how
dangerous it is from the case fatality
rate right our Point has been look this
disease as much as it's not all that
deadly is very destructive right it is
very destructive across a wide range of
organs which likely has something to do
with the protocols that its ancestor was
exposed to in Wuhan right where you know
for example caged animals did not have
to function in order to pass it on right
a mink in the wild
that gets sick with the virus has to
function as a mink in order to pass on
whatever disease it has so the disease
has an interest in not making the mink
dysfunctional if you've caged a bunch of
ferrets together so that they're
slobbering all over each other it's
losing their ability to smell and
therefore feed themselves but it doesn't
matter because they're eating ferret
Chow right the point is you have created
an environment in which a pathogen does
not need to worry about damaging tissues
that don't help it because it doesn't
matter right so did that it's the
evolution of sloppiness it is it is it
is an environment that is highly
tolerant of sloppiness and so
what we are now looking at I mean look
yeah this is not a Precision pathogen
right it's see it seems representing
like a spike protein and see how we
gotta Target this thing and it's the
thing that may be really you know
causing a lot of cellular damage but it
causes such widespread damage and so
many different systems and ways and yes
the CFR the case fatality rate is
probably not
we were saying from the beginning is
probably not and I would say now
definitely not the indicator to be using
to assess whether or not this is a
dangerous virus look at excess mortality
over time there we go here we go yes not
looking good yes and actually one of the
um I was reading a blog post not on sub
stack very surprising to see any blog
post not on substack these days but um
yeah you want to show it radagast
um yeah anyway this is
radagast is the guy who wrote it who
actually strikes me as a very
interesting uh interesting author he did
a good analysis I don't know it and I
can't see it yet yeah but anyway it'll
it'll pop up here
why was I raising him I don't know your
blog post on a sub stack written try the
only way to deal with an unfree world is
to become so absolutely free that your
very ex existence is an active Rebellion
cool uh why were you bringing this up I
do not know this is the first time I've
seen it
um I can't remember exactly I mean it
seems to me that uh I think it's a he
the his analysis is excellent with
respect to the complex systems point
right he does not overly interpret what
we have just learned but he he sort of
speculates responsibly about it
um it's it's a very good post I would
also recommend
hold on just a second after mRNA
vaccination the immune response can
spike is Shifting to igg4 so this is
that's just a summary of the science
Immunology paper we were just talking
about yeah okay yeah
um
you know I can't remember exactly it'll
come back to me I'm sure but uh but uh I
don't have it but I would also recommend
Jessica Rose has done a number of pieces
she has actually been uh quite good on
the question of attenuation but also on
the question of pathologies that may be
arising from this I would advise real
caution here because
the fact that IGG 4 is known to be
associated with something like the
development of cancer doesn't really
tell you what role it's playing and
therefore we can't leap to conclusions
about the connection between certain
things can I just say before you go on
I've not seen this post before
um but I'm looking at it and for those
just listening she starts the very
beginning of the article which she
titles IGG 4 related disease means
fibrosis and organ destruction that
leads to death eventually
the article begins let's get some
definitions out of the way she defines
fibrosis connective tissue collagen type
1 collagen and presumably more and just
that starting with that right up front
so that the reader can if they're if
they don't already own those terms in
their head and they can read them
without having to refer back they know
exactly where to find them and you know
compare that to the science Immunology
paper which I think was well done
but I ended up highlighting all of these
acronyms through it just as a way like
the first time they would use them like
I don't like I can't keep track of all
of this and so you know this this is not
necessary this is not new but even the
way that Rose has
written her piece there which I haven't
read
I immediately know that she is at least
attempting to be a clear Communicator
such that people can come to their own
conclusions and that is you know that's
that's not standard scientific
communication style in part because it
takes more words and paper used to be at
a premium and journals used to be
printed on paper like that's the sort of
explanation for why you have this really
tight sort of telepathic scientific
writing style uh but there's not much
excuse for that now and even just having
a little sidebar glossary for all the
terms on a paper like this would would
help a lot and that does it it it
creates a barrier to entry for almost
everyone the way that that Rose article
looks like it shouldn't have really like
I I don't think her article has that
buried entry she's inviting everyone in
to to read and to assess and frankly
this is part of what those who would
erect the barriers to entry really don't
want us doing like they don't like what
we're doing they presumably don't like
what she's doing there like what a lot
of these doctors and researchers are
doing saying you know what I actually
did train in something like this or
related to this and I can assess these
things and so I'm going to communicate
to all y'alls who don't necessarily you
know want to read science Immunology but
we can assess it and say something about
what it actually says and for many that
is basically a breach a breach of a
contract between Elite and not Elite
between educated and not educated it
Britain it brings
power an agency back to people where it
belongs so the the distinction I've
drawn is between what I would call terms
of art which are a necessary evil yes
these are terms that we have to have in
order to communicate about things so
igg4 for example you know you need a
term to refer to this special subclass
of antibodies in order to have that
discussion
um but it'd be it's better if you don't
have it whereas jargon which is the
alternative is the
barriers to entry that are placed by
so-called experts to keep people from
understanding what they're saying so
that only the experts can discuss it and
they don't get exposed for what they
don't know
um so anyway yeah Jessica Rose does a
great job
of bringing you in by just saying look
here are the things you're going to need
to know to understand what I'm talking
about here
so we do have
um a
tremendous issue with nested complex
systems that have been interfered with
in a radically novel way that is now
having a consequence we can measure that
nobody fully understands but may be
connected to any one of a number of
pathologies that have been seen you know
could be connected to Rapid cancers
could be connected to fibrous clot-like
developments as as Jessica Rose argues
but the real answer is
stay tuned yeah we will find out more
about what this means over time there
will no doubt be a an insane propaganda
campaign designed to demonize those who
become interested in this because
frankly it is at the very least a
tremendous challenge
um to those who are arguing that there
is a role for
um for these so-called vaccines here
um mRNA vaccines and and therapeutic
treatment in general and gain a function
research right yeah this we have opened
Pandora's Box and
um run out the clock on all of our good
options and deployed technologies that
have uh made things far worse and at
some point
at some point
we should stop using whatever mechanism
it is that's telling us what to do next
because we are doing ourselves more harm
right and uh what I would like to know
is what we have done collectively
that has been of any value whatsoever
right we caused the problem apparently
we then exacerbated the problem sure
um at some point not listening to the
people who set any of those plans in
motion would be like a first step to
doing something reasonable I would think
sounds like misinformation to me Brett
that's what they call me
misinformation yes I
did okay
um
I was gonna say in stupider news but it
couldn't possibly be oh the Lancet
which was has been considered one of the
Premier Medical journals although as we
said at the top of the hour and as we've
said here before uh it has sort of long
since been understood including by many
doctors to not really be all that
serious after all
but they confirmed that if you will this
this month December 2022 when they
published this study
and I'm just going to read some bits
from it um but don't put up my screen
just yet actually
um
I actually feel like I should give a
trigger warning before talking about
this because uh if there's there's sex
and types of sex and types of sexual
intercourse discussed in this article
which I think weren't just We're Not
Gonna spend a lot of time here but uh in
order to understand what this paper has
done what the authors of this paper have
done and what this journal has done by
letting them publish it in this form you
need to go into some things that some
people will consider grotesque so uh
there there you go turn off now if
you're not interested in uh learning
about some of the differences between
how women and trans women actually
engage in sexual activity so uh here we
go you can put on my screen here Zach
this again published this in December
2022 by the Lancet human monkey pox
virus infection in women and
non-barinary individuals during the 2022
outbreaks a global case series
now you might think if you just look at
the headline that it's going to be about
women and non-binary individuals that's
the problem well no I will say here as
I've said many times non-binary isn't a
thing that's not a real category but
just stop it already you're just making
that up
um the non-binary individuals the
handful I think it was literally maybe
five
um
uh that they included here were all
um female actually not a sign female at
Birth but actually female observed
female
and the problem arises with their
category of women in which about half of
the women that are included in the study
aren't women they're trans women who are
not women
so we are they're looking at Monkey box
which
for those of you who've been living
under some rock that wasn't infected by
monkey pox uh of course is mostly uh
mostly Ben an infection uh that gay Ben
get from gay sex that has mostly been
the case and so okay well yeah we should
see what's going on with women for sure
but maybe don't include a whole bunch of
men and call them women and thus further
confuse the issue so here are just a few
um
sorry it's gonna It's Gonna Wanna pop up
um
non-sexual routes of transmission
including household and occupational
exposures were reported only in CIS
women and non-binary individuals so that
is to say that once again it's um the
it's all of the men included in the
study on women are actually being
exposed through sexual routes wait wait
wait wait this is actually it's not an
important because I'm not sure why I
highlighted that one
um in trans women this is research and
context this is sort of a you know if
you don't want to read the whole article
piece in trans women
oh wait sorry oh my God
I need to see the hook I'll just read
this in trans women commercial sex work
was reported in 34 as 55 of 62
individuals and was the strongest
occupational link to infection
24 is 34 of CIS women and non-binary
people women had vaginal mucosal
involvement and 59 of 71 had vulfur
lesions one trans woman had vulvar
involvement and no disease of the of the
vagina was described perhaps reflecting
sexual activity as few trans women had
undergone gender affirming surgery
I'm gonna just keep going a little bit
here here it is HIV prevalence was very
high in trans women 50 percent
lower instas women and non-binary people
eight percent okay so the men that they
included in the study on women
were either half or more than half HIV
positive and sex workers
okay
point one
I and I'm sorry my screen does not want
to behave
uh yeah I think it's I think it's
hanging up because I'm connected there
okay now you can show it again here
similarly large case series describing
the 2022 outbreaks of monkey pox virus
have included no or few women
and that continues to this day
and large epidemiological surveillance
data sets have not differentiated
between cisgender and transgender women
because
cisgender isn't a thing that's you're
either male or female and trans people
are real but the sex that they are
matters whereas the gender that they
think they are especially if they've had
no surgery in any way does not matter at
all with regard to Monkey box
okay a few more
would you like to respond yeah I would
like to respond before yeah okay okay
you can you can give it my screen back
so I can get to the next one sec yes
is it
oh my God is it arrogant of me to think
that I'm not dumb uh yeah no it's not
arrogant for you to think you're not
done I don't think I'm dumb no I am
straining to understand this paper
because
it goes beyond jargon by pretending that
men who are trans women are something
other than men biologically it takes and
most of them are HIV positive and sex
workers right right right right yes but
I'm having trouble even getting there
because I'm struggling to keep track of
the fact that they've got women who are
men who are being lumped with other men
because they're men but the paper
doesn't say that they're all just men
because this isn't they've studied men
right
oh but they didn't they're not lumping
them with men here because they're no
men there's no there's no men in this
study
because they they are correcting
historical wrong here because monkey pox
because it mostly affects men who have
sex with other men
um have decided to look at women
right but except they didn't I mean they
did a few and then they found that among
the women who are mostly not sex workers
and not HIV HIV positive that there were
some cases of monkeypox but among the
men who think they're women
who were also mostly HIV positive and
sex workers uh that they were okay
there's just one more here
and this gets you know I didn't need to
know this but Zach if you want to show
my screen here
um the the type of sex that trans women
versus women and non-vi women which
they're calling Swiss women and
non-binary individuals the type of sex
that they have okay which includes anal
oral and anal oral only vaginal anal
vaginal oral vaginal only okay so these
three types and they've got them into
various categories
trans women
had no vaginal sex
because they're not women and they don't
have vaginas
they don't say that in the paper but
that's why but okay and women
says women are non-binary individuals
with women
no women had only anal sex only one of
them had only oral annual sex they
mostly had vaginal sex and mostly
they're not getting monkey pox
right so so you could take that off and
we're done with the grotesqueries here
now but
I guess what I'm getting at here and I
mean I realize this is your point too
but I'm just struggling trying to
wrestle it into Clarity sure
this is a very obvious result yes
everything about the result oh yeah is
perfectly obvious this is a pattern
we've seen before right I mean this is
the pattern that we saw with AIDS right
we had
um gay men were getting AIDS anal sex
was a primary route of infection at
least in the west and therefore it
wasn't something about you know
the mindset of gay men it was about the
behavior of gay men which differed from
men who weren't gay
for obvious reasons bath houses and anal
sex turned out not to be good for you
right and it turns out if you're a woman
right and you were engaged in this
Behavior then the virus didn't care that
you weren't a gay man right so the point
is the result of the paper is perfectly
straightforward it's not really
newsworthy but the insane way that they
have categorized people obscures that
result so you have to you have to do
overtime like your social justice brain
has to unpack this result so that you
can show that you can properly read
through the idea of non-binary and uh
and CIS women I mean the whole idea that
you have to read this stupid code in
order to get a perfectly obvious result
of a pattern we've seen before right
this paper should be very easy to
understand and yet they have turned it
into a
um a monstrosity of needless complexity
by pretending that law all sorts of
things that have nothing to do with
Biology are fundamentally biological and
medical yeah no and let's uh let's
definitely look at uh monkey pox
Transmission in women by doing a small
study in which half the people aren't
women
right I you know like I don't
I I don't like sort of the rad fam move
to blame the patriarchy for a whole lot
of [ __ ] yeah like what what is going on
here but really
like
what about studying women because wasn't
that the point right but no half the
people you they've not just because they
said they were an armadillo here they're
not an armadillo and they're not women
either like they're not and these are
these are
trans women but
before they've had bottom surgeries that
the idea
okay so it's waning men
I'm sorry
oh yeah yeah thank you for not saying
hallelujah
appreciate that I I mean some I know
this is wrong but I'd prefer it to be
waxing men
um right and I don't like that image
either no that's uh
hairless at some level yeah yeah okay
which is okay um so just one last thing
here so I went I was like oh God
the Lancet is really far gone what the
hell and I just went onto their site and
found uh the the last op-ed that the
landside is publishing this year
it's not the last op-ed ever uh we
couldn't hope but no I don't think so
it's called pasture's Legacy in 21st
century medicine yeah yeah so here it is
and again I'll link it but here's a PDF
um so yeah the lancetbids 2022 idea with
a commemoration of Louis Pasteur
and then a little bio of Louis Pasteur
um but two little
um
highlights here it's short
the 21st century is seeing a changing
landscape of infectious diseases old and
new pathogens are emerging under growing
pressure of anthropogenic forces
anthropogenic forces they mean Anthony
fauci well and you know Labs would gain
a function research right yeah of course
you don't have those labs without the
funding and you don't have the funding
without Anthony found oh didn't he just
step down or is about to I think we'll
see funding
you think it's over
I don't think it's over one more one
more from the lancet's final op-ed of
the year the unstable political no the
unstable social and political context in
which we live our lives is creating the
new Public Health let's start over
I'm adding all sorts of words that
aren't there the unstable social and
political context in which we live our
lives is creating new public health
challenges
an infodemic has seen the rapid spread
of misinformation that resonates with
people in ways that expert advice does
not
vaccine hesitancy is now a major barrier
to fighting infectious diseases
particularly in high income countries
many parents are reluctant to vaccinate
their children because of concerns about
vaccine safety despite reassurances from
doctors and public health authorities
this hesitancy reflects a broader
breakdown of trust in the state and in
scientists
excuse me
a breakdown of trust in the state
yeah yeah that's the problem that is
causing a breakdown of trust in the
state by people especially in wealthy
countries is causing the infidemic
the infinite so the a I would just say
infodemic is one of those terms that
strikes me that somebody Advanced it in
a spitballing session and nobody in the
spitballing session was smart enough to
point down point out that that suggests
the uncontrolled spreading of
information
which is more or less what happened they
couldn't control the spread of
information and it got away from them
and then here we are talking about what
actually happened
yeah
this hesitancy reflects a broader
breakdown of trust in the state
and in scientists
I don't remember
even when I was a
proud Democrat
ever being expected to have trust in the
state
that seems like a really new and you
know cringy is the shallow end of the
pool of what that is really bad
suggestion that what we need is
trust in the state
and in scientists who say what the state
wants them to say which is the unspoken
part of this they keep they keep telling
us this right I mean it's amazing I I
think it was this year that Mal
information showed up as a form of
terrorism which you will of course
recall is it might have been 2021 but
you know the years go by so fast they do
they go by so quickly but Mal
information
as originally presented by the
Department of Homeland Security was uh
things that were based in fact that
caused you to lose trust in government
and that is a form of Terrors I mean
they actually said it right so they did
they didn't say that yes they did
if the facts cause you to lose trust in
your government you're a terrorist
that's their point and
um
I'm not sure where we go from there but
it does seem like that's an indication
of which side they're on it does yes
that they're going to use the state in
ways that will cause us to become
factually Disturbed at them and then
they're going to paint us as terrorists
that's that's pretty much the summation
of the last couple years yeah it feels
kind of accurate yeah and um I don't
know and the fact that the truth is not
on their side
he's not helping right it's maddening to
them that the facts are on our side that
is really I can imagine being troubled
where I in their shoes which I would
never allow myself to be but
yeah so I I guess I wish that I had put
something else together here to end 2022
on an awesome note oh I didn't read the
whole paper but um I actually didn't
read the paper at all but science uh
reports
I don't know why I trust them but the
science reports uh you can just show
this so I literally have not read the
paper that it's even reporting on glass
frogs become see-through by hiding their
blood
their Boreal amphibians store almost all
of their red blood cells in their livers
when they camouflage so these are near
tropical arboreal fruits isn't that so
freaking cool yeah okay so here we go
yeah and I I haven't read the paper I
don't even you know maybe the paper
sucks although
um either they do this or they don't so
glass frogs
this is Clay to frogs that live in um
lowland tropical rainforests in the new
world and I've only seen one or two
maybe they're they tend to be really
high up and they're cryptic they're
super cryptic like the pictures that
you'll see of them like this make them
look really not cryptic but they're
basically transparent which is why
they're called glass frogs and so this
new study which again I have not read
I've only read the science news version
of it
um
apparently
um they divert their blood into their
livers to help them disappear and they
spend like half they spend the night
with their blood in the livers when
they're not moving around aren't they
nocturnal they spend the day um it's
probably the day they spend their their
yeah which would make sense because
their camouflage is liable to be during
the day when they snooze on leaves yeah
it would be pretty useless in the dark
so you have to go through all that
effort yeah and so actually you know
so I worked I worked on two of like the
only clans of diurnal frogs frogs
poisonous enough to be out during the
day and not get eaten yeah they're
flipping the bird at everyone going like
you can't eat me talking poisonous but
this is a little bit like
um the
camouflage of
um
Honduran white bats yeah cool because
Honduras they don't hide their blood in
their livers do they no I don't think so
during white bats have the most
shockingly white coats which is strange
because when you actually see them in
their little tents they look very
conspicuous but without shining a light
on them in the darkness of their tents
um their coats reflect green they do
yeah oh I didn't know that yeah
um so anyway yeah the idea of being
camouflaged to hide in your Roost during
the day because you're out at night and
day is When You're vulnerable
to unite those two things anyway that's
cool yeah it is cool trying to remember
what the um
the call of a glass frog I remember do
am I wrong that it's like it's almost
like a glass being uh like a crystal
glass being hit yeah I want to say yes
and then I think that I sometimes
conflated them with another clade and so
I'm not 100 sure I they were
they were hard enough to to locate uh
and they're a lot yeah there's a there's
a lot of frog call going on in a in a
jungle at night
um and I don't I don't remember for sure
all right well that's that's definitely
known I just don't remember and I want
to say yes but I feel like I often
completed them with a different frog all
right well different Clayton we will
seek it out yeah or not oh I will okay
I'm gonna ask you about it okay yeah
okay uh well that brings us to the end
of 2022 I mean not really we've got
um boy we've got like nine and a half
hours left
[Music]
finish off this here in just a moment
and take a 15 minute break or so and
come back with answers to your questions
which you can ask at
darkhorsemissions.com and we last week I
think we got to all of them actually uh
we usually don't uh so there's no
promise no assurance that we'll get to
your questions if you ask them but we
try and if you have any logistical
questions you can go to
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com consider
joining our patreons reading our book
hunter-gatherers guided 21st century
it's about to be published in check
actually no that's not true it's it's
now going to be published in check but
we don't know when
but the Chinese version is coming out
soon yes it is yeah okay so
um until either 15 minutes from now or
next year
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
thank you
[Music]